Once Upon a Time Yahoo was one of the
largest internet companies in the world
they offered everything from search and
email to weather and stocks they were
basically the Google of the late 1990s
and early 2000s with a monstrous
valuation of $25 billion way back then
but ever since then it's only been
downhill for Yahoo Yahoo only pulls in a
mere fraction of the internet traffic
that they used to and this has trans
lated to underwhelming Stats across the
company at this point they don't even
control 3% of the search engine Market
which is three times less than even Bing
and it's a similar case with email as
well they're no longer even a public
company and they keep getting tossed
around from one owner to another for
pennies on the dollar in fact Apollo
funds recently bought yahu and AOL both
the fmer once $100 billion companies and
other businesses all for just $5 billion
but more than all of that likely the
worst Omen for Yahoo is public
perception I don't think people
necessarily have a negative view of
Yahoo but at the same time it's not
positive either if you ask the average
person about Yahoo their response would
probably be along the lines of oh yeah
they used to be really big back in the
day I think I still have a Yahoo email
from back then but I don't use it
anymore in other words the general
public has very much moved on from Yahoo
and most would point to Google as being
the biggest reason for yaku's downfall
and at first glance that makes sense
after all it was Google that basically
overtook every industry that Yahoo used
to dominate it's the classic case of a
new modern company displacing a legacy
giant with raw Innovation and charm but
when we peel back the layers you'll see
that almost all of Yahoo's demise was
actually their own fault so here's what
really happened to yahu the company that
threw away
[Music]
everything to understand what really
happened to Yahoo we first have to
understand how they even became
successful in the first place usually
when we talk about dying companies on
this channel we're talking about some
Legacy electronics company that was
founded in the' 60s or 7s or even in the
early 1900s but Yahoo doesn't exactly
fit this profile if anything Yahoo is
more of a new age company having not
been founded till 1994 Yahoo actually
has a very similar origin story to
Google you know how Google was founded
by two Stanford Graduate students Sergey
Bren and Larry Page in the 1990s well
yahooo was also founded by two Stanford
Graduate students Jerry Yang and David
phow in the 1990s Yahoo even had a
crappy original name just like Google it
was originally called Jerry and David's
Guide to the worldwide web as the the
name suggests Yahoo started off as a way
to better navigate the worldwide web but
not by searching instead Yahoo was more
of an online phone book it was basically
just a massive directory of websites
that probably sounds rather clunky for
2023 standards but back in 1994 this
itself was pretty useful in fact before
the name Yahoo was even chosen arduo
would receive over 100,000 visitors and
1 million views to their website
surprised by this traffic arduo would
decide to make this side project an
official business and name it yahoo
which stands for yet another
hierarchically organized Oracle and with
that Yahoo was Off to the Races just one
month after being Incorporated Yahoo
would raise $3 million from Michael
Moritz and seoa capital and just a year
after that Yahoo would IPO on April 12th
1996 reaching a valuation of $1 billion
let me put that another way Yahoo went
from Z 0 to1 billion within a matter of
2 years and 4 months and for most of
that time period they weren't even an
official company yeah I think it's safe
to say that Yahoo very much stumbled
into the Limelight and this was likely
one of their biggest shortfalls Yahoo
wasn't some sort of super wellth thought
out company it was something that kind
of just happened and this would become
really apparent when Yahoo was tasked
with maintaining and growing this
success luckily for Yahoo though they
never had to deal with this during the
1990s thanks Toom hype instead of
growing a strong Foundation Yahoo would
have the luxury of expanding into
everything underneath the sun using Doom
money for example they would launch a
bunch of international variants of Yahoo
this included Yahoo Japan Yahoo UK Yahoo
Germany and Yahoo France just to name a
few they would even start their own
print magazine called Yahoo internet
life yeah I don't think you'd be
surprised to here that this magazine
didn't last all that that long but Yahoo
did have a few Stellar launches as well
like yaho mail and yaho Finance in 1997
but if there was any way to describe
yaho in the late 1990s it would be that
they were all over the place like a lot
of tech companies try to do Yahoo was
trying to be everything for everyone and
who could blame them they were growing
rapidly had access to seemingly infinite
capital and they would even be added to
the S&P 500 it wasn't until the turn of
the century and things cool down that
Yahoo would realize that by trying to be
everything for everyone they had
actually become nothing to no
[Music]
one being all over the place and the
lacking Focus was just half the story
though much of Yahoo's demise can
actually be attributed to Pure
incompetence and poor decisionmaking and
likely the best example of this was
their history of Acquisitions
acquisition can be a GameChanger some of
the most successful Tech ventures of all
time weren't built in house they were
Acquisitions this includes the likes of
YouTube Android Instagram and WhatsApp
all of which were game changers for
Google and Facebook Yahoo has had their
own share of gamechanging Acquisitions
only it wasn't gamechanging in a good
way also it wasn't just one or two bad
deals either Yahoo consistently made
terrible deals starting with Google you
see Larry and Sergey didn't initially
have massive Ambitions with Google as
far as they were concerned Google was
just a school project and they were
willing to sell for a generous exit of
$1 million in 1998 to none other than
Yahoo Yahoo however would have course
refuse and honestly this is quite
understandable they probably see dozens
of people like Larry and Sergey walk
through the door and most of them likely
end up as nothing so it's understandable
that Yahoo didn't want to take a flyer
with Google in 98 but you know what they
did want to take a flyer with the most
overvalued internet company of all time
broadcast.com I'm not even exaggerating
broadcast.com is regularly cited as the
worst acquisition of all time as yahu
would pay $5.7 billion for the company
the company only had a total of 570,000
users meaning that Yahoo paid
$10,000 per user if that wasn't bad
enough Yahoo would end up shutting down
the company just a few years later and
that was just the most notable example
Yahoo also blew $3.6 billion on Gio
cities 1.63 billion on Overture 1
billion on Tumblr and 850 million on
right media clearly not a very strong
track record but honestly the deals that
Yahoo missed out on are even more
notable remember how they missed out on
Google in '98 well that was just the
first time that they missed out on
Google it turns out that they would
somehow get get a second chance in 2002
and they would blow it once again this
time Google was no longer just a college
project it was a legitimate business
that was rapidly eating up yaku's market
share yaku realized this and would offer
to buy Google for $3 billion Google
would counter with $5 billion but Yahoo
was not willing to budge for perspective
Google would reach 100 billion just 3
years later all right maybe yahoo is
just unlucky when it comes to Google if
another winner walk through the door
surely they would pounce right well
Google isn't the end of the story
because yahu also missed out on Facebook
in 2006 and this one was the saddest of
them all actually everything was good to
go both parties had agreed to an
acquisition for $1.1 billion but at the
last second Yahoo would reduce their
offer to $800 million and Zuckerberg
would walk away in other words yahu has
lost out on trillion dollar
opportunities on three separate
occasions I'm just kidding after all
this is Yahoo we're talking about in
2013 Yahoo had the opportunity to buy
either Tumblr for 1.1 billion Hulu for
1.3 billion or Netflix for 4 billion
Yahoo would end up choosing Tumblr while
Netflix became the best performing stock
of the decade to be honest I didn't even
know that this was within the realm of
possibility they literally passed on
three Fang companies on four separate
occasions while simultaneously making
the worst Acquisitions of History it's
actually wild they somehow managed to
perfectly pick all the losers and miss
out on all the winners sounds a lot like
your average Joe trying to day trade and
honestly that was pretty much what
happened yaho was led by extremely
intelligent people but not exactly
strong business people Google actually
had the exact same problem Larry and
Sergey are some of the smartest people
in the world but they weren't all that
great at being CEOs
and that's why they hired a career
businessman named Eric Schmidt to be CEO
and Eric is really the guy who made the
business out of Google work yahu however
didn't have Eric and they would
continuously blow it year after year and
if you thought their history of
Acquisitions was terrible well it gets
even
[Music]
worse despite all of their blunders and
shortcomings Microsoft who was desperate
to fight against Google would offer to
buy out Yahoo in 2008 for $45 billion
while this was a lot lower than Yahoo
Peak valuation of $125 billion it was
quite generous given that Yahoo was
getting destroyed by Google but Yahoo
didn't see it this way they saw it as an
under market value offer so they would
decline the deal and this basically
sealed their fate Yahoo would continue
getting destroyed by Google over the
next decade and they would eventually be
bought out by Verizon for a measly $4.5
billion today Yahoo is still around and
they still have a decent user count just
because of how big they were back in
their Glory Days but make no mistake
Yahoo is a shell of their former selves
and what happened to them is really
quite a shame Yahoo basically
accidentally stumbled upon a gold mine
in the '90s but they didn't exactly know
how to manage all this newfound wealth
they ended up expanding into every
sector under the sun while not doing any
of them all that well this would have
been the end for most companies but
thanks to Doom funding and hype they
were able to overcome these massive
mistakes they had a golden second
opportunity to really double down on
their core products and audience but
they never did that and Google would end
up eating their lunch now this would
have surely been the end for basically
all companies but Yahoo had even more
opportunities first there was Google
then Google again then Facebook then a
bailout from Microsoft and then Netflix
yet Yahoo would pass on all these
opportunities only to end up being
bought out by ryzen for $4.5 billion and
honestly yahu has no one to blame but
themselves you know how 70% of lottery
winners end up going bankrupt within a
few years well that's exactly what
happened to Yahoo they got insanely
lucky but without the right business
mindset they just weren't able to keep
up their success despite having every
opportunity to do so another company
that threw away everything is Xerox
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one